no hot lava what's wrong - boring what's
wrong with you what's wrong with this
guy he doesn't like making money you
know there's probably there's probably
some charity right down the street where
you could go give them all your dough
from twitch and give them all your time
just like being an uncle you get all the
fun stuff and not on evil artwork yeah I
mean we we we launched a fund and we
almost probably 90% of the companies
were super involved with well either
through the board or being on the board
or just they just need help I mean you
know this I mean young entrepreneurs
that they might have a great idea and
and be smart people but they're gonna
come across things they just need help
navigating and-and-and or connecting
them a minute within our honestly the
worst companies need the most help and I
can't save them the best companies never
need my help and there's everybody else
between companies that I really don't
have any influence in I just get to take
credit in the end and I was like I dig
that honesty best companies truly is
probably the best one it's done pretty
well and I'm like a needy girlfriend
like Silicon Valley companies doing
super well and you know I'll text the
founder to be like hey what's up you
want to jam on ideas you want me to help
you with this problem and he's like dude
I'm just busy I hate I hate when
investors ask what what I did we won't
tell nil when he gets here well I what I
do is I said monthly updates and they're
very clear and succinct and I'm very
transparent and they're like how can I
help I'm like you can't unless you have
ideas and you can tell me how you can
help do it but I don't like I can't
think of anything yeah like it's like I
don't know how can you help you know and
I mean it's like what are you gonna come
in here and write emails for me and do
work for me I mean like I don't know
they're like you need a choice anyone
I'm like who do you know I don't know
that's I mean I think the intro part is
big in our world and so on you know in
health and wellness fitness nutrition I
mean it's it's you know I've been doing
this for 30 years just as an athlete so
I've gotten to know everybody I mean if
if we make it investors are just
examples but if we make an investment in
a company like amp human and they need
and it'd be very obvious that they'd be
connected to Strava and vice versa it
would take them a month to get a call I
think you're different though thank you
Sam well that's your value is well
that's our value yeah everyone knows
that you know everyone I mean you're a
celebrity like you could get touch with
everyone but like if you know I'm an
investor you're an investor it's like
they don't know who I know yeah and I
probably don't know that many people who
they can't just called email yeah do you
know what I mean is that what your angle
is gonna be is that you have there's
that and we call I mean we refer to it
as the flywheel just because with you
know now the one show the second show
the move is about 15 million downloads a
year and so you know once that started
to really take off then I I was getting
all this interesting deal flow I thought
to myself we should just sort of fund
and invest in some of these companies
and and then what happens when we
reintegrate or occasionally integrate
some of our companies back into that
audience right that course sticky group
of 15 million people and so that's
that's what well here's Neil that's what
we bring to it
yeah so yeah I mean there's the
connections there is the flywheel
there's the audience and then we got a
pretty kick-ass Advisory Board that we
pull into whether it's you know
researching deal flow or or sitting on
boards so
[Music]
you